tell me when ready
Oh
hello folks another day another lecture
and yesterday when we adjourned some
questions remained let's see about
motion and I covered the history of
motion and after that you know some
issues remain and one of them was the
scientific definition of motion
efficiency the one that I proposed and
my son Adrian who is on the other side
of the law
table here he he questioned it and we
had a good fight over it i won as always
i'm going to talk about also the
question of whether motion is continuous
and i want to raise another issue which
is that definitions have to be
comprehensive in fact they are for the
purposes of the rope hypothesis we build
this foundation and all these
definitions are interrelated so let me
go on with the history let me do a
summary again of synthesis of what I
said yesterday
essentially I'm saying that the debate
over motion I think started with Plato
now he wrote it down but I'm sure it
started even before with Socrates but
that's around the time when it started
fourth century BC that's a good time
frame for when they started debating the
word motion in a even caught scientific
or philosophical matter when it when
they realized it was an important word
and and the problem again is that both
Plato and the guy who comes after him
who is his student Aristotle they wrote
about it but neither one really defined
the terms what the term motion what they
did was they use synonyms okay they use
the word change alteration words of that
nature and and
Plato was a little more using his
intention was to use the word more in
terms of what the soul does he want to
show that the origin of motion starts
with the soul the soul is what
penetrates the body and the body is
essentially a statue until the slow
penetrates it and gets it moving
Aristotle comes later and he says now
look there was an unmoved mover he's the
original guy I guess we're talking about
God here and what he's saying
essentially is that you know there was
this chain reaction these dominoes and
it was a first domino which was unmoved
or or could not move itself okay and
apparently after that it started moving
and began the rolling of the dominoes so
anyway you want to interpret that the
point here is that neither one defined
the word motion in a scientific manner
that's the first issue and we go through
many centuries and nobody really touches
the word they just rely on what both
Aristotle and Plato said until we get to
the 13th century we have st. Thomas
Aquinas and what Thomas does is he takes
Aristotle's view essentially and he says
and the reason he takes that view is he
wants to prove the existence of God his
perfect that his first proof has to do
with motion and has to do with the
argument presented by her saw well that
there is a first unmoved mover and so
essentially that's where that goes it's
not very scientific again he doesn't
have a definition he just uses from what
Aristotle and so there are no
definitions up to that point now we come
to the 17th century we get to Newton
Isaac Newton and there were a couple
people in between there that touched the
word motion but as far as like a major
discussion on motion I guess you could
say Newton because he came up with a
three
laws of motion but again Newton does not
define to word motion okay in fact he
says you know specifically in his folium
to the Principia he says i do not define
lalalalala and motion because we already
know what they mean okay so he has no
definition and after that we get to
really earn stein is probably the next
guy he deals with it at the beginning in
the 20th century and he talks about he's
got this paper it's called under
electrode I'm and electrodynamics of
moving bodies moving bodies you would
think he was gonna talk about motion and
he does talk about motion but not from
the motion point-of-view he doesn't
define motion he talks about it from the
time point of view he introduces time
and we get to today and we don't have a
definition if you look it up in the
dictionary what you're gonna find is a
synonym the word change specifically so
motion has changed and changes motion we
haven't learned anything and that's the
status today okay so what have I done
I've introduced a definition which I
maintain is scientific because it can be
used consistently and it does not rely
on synonyms and we do need to define the
word motion for the purposes of physics
we can't avoid the subject and so it's
part of the lexicon or the grammar words
that we absolutely need to do physics
and before that you have three other
words and I'm gonna put them up here
that's the scientific definition that I
presented yesterday it consists of at
least four definitions we have the word
object we have the word distance
location and right and only after that
can we get to the word motion the first
three of these are static concepts there
is no motion involved for example in
distance we're not talking about
unrolling a measuring tape we're not
talking about counting seconds on a
clock what we're doing is saying that
you know this is simply a separation
between objects and objects that that
was
and then location is the set of
distances from every object in the
universe every atom whatever you level
you want to deal with to the test object
now we get to the first dynamic concept
and that's the word motion when you find
there's two or more locations okay and
that's the status now now what is the
issue with the with these words the the
issue is that you know is this a
scientific definition and my son said he
doesn't agree or he's or maybe he's got
a better definition I don't know what
the what his argument will be here but
he says that we have a problem because
time is involved in my definition and I
try to separate those two and I'm saying
the following for time you need memory
you need a living entity or a recorder a
video tape recorder to show that this
object was over here and now it's over
here
okay you need that memory you need to
show two locations for time but you need
to compare one set of motions against
another in other words time is a
comparison of two motions motions of two
objects is to two motion in other words
motions of two objects you need to have
two objects to do to do time you need to
compare them and you need memory okay
that's for time what I'm saying is many
motion doesn't require that motion is
just a definition if an object by
definition if I'm gonna give a
presentation I'm saying somebody asked
me what is motion I'm gonna say two or
more locations and that's by definition
as you can see in the definition of
motion there is no requirement for an
observer if an object by itself
no human says no no life existing in the
Univision moves has two or more
locations we say that it moved by
definition that's what I'm saying with
that definition I'm saying that if we're
gonna use this consistently we gotta say
well did the move
move well did you observe or see it move
no that's not the issue the issue is did
the moon occupy two or more locations if
it did we call that motion we refer to
that phenomenon as motion that's what
I'm saying
conversely time you need to have two
things move and compare them so you need
memory now you need someone to make a
relation between this motion and I'll
give an example for example the motion
of the earth around the Sun against the
motion of the seconds on my clock or my
watch or the minutes or the hours or
whatever and what am I saying here I'm
saying that the earth moved 30
kilometers when my second move one
second in other words went from one
stick to the other so I'm comparing the
motion of the earth against the motion
of my watch that's we're doing a
comparison that's what I'm saying is
time time is a comparison of two motions
okay
and again well I don't put time in there
because we don't need time in physics or
in science that's why I don't put time
time is not a crucial work we don't need
time okay and that's why I never include
I just criticize it and I'm saying this
is what the mathematicians are saying
when they say time so I'm putting words
in their mouth because they they don't
put them in their mouth they they can't
tell you what time is I'm saying this is
what you're saying
it is okay that's what time is and
that's what everybody understands by
time because people get these these
weird definitions time is what our clock
measures or we don't know what time is
or you know they get all these kinds of
answers and all those answers are
unscientific the scientific definition
of time of what they're referring to
when they say time is look when the
earth move 30 kilometers my second the
second hand on my clock move one second
you know and you multiply that times
five you move five seconds the earth
moved 150 kilometers that that's what
we're saying we're comparing two motions
and you can do that with almost anything
you can say well the dog ran it took
five seconds you're comparing to how
much time the dog went from A to B and
how much time your second or your minute
or your hour on your clock went from
one place to another when you say an
action happened after another okay so a
hat sorry B happens after a yeah now
what are you invoking time when you see
that yes you are but you're invoking a
different kind of time and I've got that
in my book no let me specify what is
qualitative time
the other one is quantitative time when
we say before and after yesterday and
today you know we're not really
referring to a clock or to any
measurement we're just saying this came
before that you know and then we were
talking about qualitative time only
qualitative qualitative sense we're not
invoking seconds or minutes or hours but
when we invoke seconds minutes or hours
now we're getting the measuring tape
right we're using pre-established units
we're bringing that into the discussion
and that's a little different than
talking about qualitative time but
account ativ time you're saying is
qualitative time is also the
relationship between two objects but in
the case of one like when you're talking
about seconds minutes hours a
quantitative time now you're now you've
got some pre-established units because
i'm sure if we go to another planet and
they have a different year different min
in a different second maybe they they
have a different measure of time because
we have agreed here on earth on what is
a second but maybe in another planet
they have a different second maybe their
second is a second and a half for all we
know right I mean I'm sure if we go and
live in Mars right there seconds got to
be a little different than ours because
they take longer to make the year in the
year the second one is established or
ridging based on the year okay yeah it's
a fraction of the year well I think it's
thirty-eight thousand and four hundred
or something like I can't remember the
exact number I think and I don't know if
that's the hours or the minutes or the
second but the point here is that no
it's can't be the seconds that's got to
be Millions
but the point here is that you know if
you go a different planet it's going to
have different time and you have a
different civilization they'll have
different time
in fact we had different time when you
know we had the original people you know
the Indians like the Aztecs and so on
they you they used a different calendar
they you know they used I'm sure their
calendar did not match the Roman
calendar or the Christian calendar and
and we're talking about calendars here
but still that's time that's a measure
of time but the point here is that you
know those are pre-established units
first you've got established a unit say
I'm going to talk about the second you
measure and you say this is gonna be a
second and now you're gonna use that to
qualify time in a quantitative manner
whereas when you talk about before and
after you're just talking about
qualitative time but in both cases
you're talking about the comparison of
two motions what is before and after you
have to compare the motion of one guy to
the motion of another then you have time
you have I mean first of all there
everything moves in the universe but
you're saying nothing move that means we
froze the universe I would think there's
no time I guess that's where the Big
Bang started nothing moved yeah okay and
again I we have to put in the right
context we're talking about a scientific
definition here
and all I'm saying is that when I
pronounce the word motion and I say the
moon moved or the dog moved or the rock
move whatever whenever I say that all
I'm saying is that thing occupied two or
more locations that's what I'm gonna say
that's that's my definite that's how I'm
gonna use definition so so I don't need
to say well did I see the dog move did I
see the rock move no I'm saying if the
rock occupies two or more locations
we're gonna call that motion that's the
way we got interpreted in the case of
time we can't do that in case of time we
absolutely need to observe have memory
or to record a record or some some video
or whatever and it's got to compare two
motions and only then can you have that
relationship that we call time
but when you say motion is an object
occupying two or more locations your
Voki frames okay and that's that's
another thing that that's the next issue
and let me clarify that before you get
into the question because maybe I'll
answer your question with what I'm gonna
answer now and that's the issue of
continuous is time is motion continuous
and according to my definitions we got a
problem because you're saying we'll hold
it if you see the definition there on on
the screen it says location right and
distance is from all objects to the
target and motion is to location two or
more locations but if location is a
static concept and motion is the first
dynamic concept we got a little bit of a
contradiction there or a seeming
contradiction that appears that there's
a contradiction location is kind of like
discrete in our minds we're saying well
location it's a static position of an
object you know this is the location
that cross-section of time in the
universe one frame of the universe rises
right actually motion right so so we got
a cross-section of time in the universe
or one frame in the universe and so now
we have one frame and now we said well
motion is two or more frames that's what
we're apparently saying right and so you
say well okay if I look at a movie right
and I see one frame and another frame
and another frame it's discrete we have
all these discrete locations we run the
tape and now we have motion but you know
at the nitty-gritty it looks like you
know we have all these chopped up
locations forming forming motion that's
why they call it moving pictures
pictures right moving picture motion
pictures right but no no let me clarify
that when there's two ways of looking at
this what motion is and what a motion
picture is here we have a frame here we
have another frame here we have another
another one that's the way we always
seen the films right
now what if we see them lengthwise
instead of sideways right we see them
lengthwise and they're stuck together
one to the other so we have a book all
the pages of the book right one right
next to another that's how we should see
location location you can't chop
location in half right and you can't
chop one of these frames of the universe
in half like sideways like one frame
from another and you cut it there you
splice it no here we're talking about
continuous locations okay and they're
all stuck to each other because it's not
like the object stops at this location
and then says okay two minutes later
yeah then goes to the next frame that's
how we do the film but that's not what
happens out there in physics into a real
world in the real world it's a
continuous locations so they're all
touching each other and the best way to
look at this is not sideways as frames
in a film you got to look at them as the
pages of a book they're you know they're
all one right next to another they're
all touching neck to neck and no matter
where you cut that motion you're gonna
find a location that's how we got a look
at so so okay yeah but let me clarify
one more thing which is very very
important keep this in mind and this is
important okay the word continues in
physics is an adjective it cannot be
used in the context of motion or
location which are concepts yeah
continuous is an adjective
discrete and continues only can be used
to qualify objects you can you can say
the tape you can say the table is
continues for auric or better still a
cube an ideal cube is not thought of as
made of little pieces and that notes
continues made of a single piece that's
a nigel cube is perfect
there's no it has no holes in it so so
from a conceptual point of view a cube
is continuing a circle is continued
okay so that's continuous that's where
you can use the word continuous you
cannot say that that information is
continues yeah keep in mind keep in mind
that we have a new language here and
it's important to understand this
language adjectives that are at words
that are adjectives in ordinary speech
cannot be used cannot be transferred
without any scrutiny into physics in
physics if the word motion in in
ordinary speech the word motion is a
noun in physics it's a verb orbit is is
a noun in ordinary speech in science and
physics it's a verb orbit is what
something does not what something is not
even though you say well I can talk
about orbit that's an ordinary speech
you can't talk about orbit in science
you cannot say and I always used this
example you cannot say the orbit of
Jupiter I'm going to talk today about
the orbit of Jupiter that's a wrong
language you get to say Jupiter orbits
orbit is a verb comes after the noun
Jupiter's the noun that's what we have
to do it in physics again if you're
talking about the itinerary or the
highway well I mean if we're well for
example that's we're talking about the
yellow brick road or are we talking
about the itinerary along the yellow
brick road so we're talking about motion
the itinerary the trajectory that's a
concept that's motion but if you're
talking about the lows now again if
you're talking about the road you're
talking about them now but if you're
talking about the itinerary it's not a
noun it's a verb I did the word
itinerary in physics is a verb how would
you rephrase the orbit of Jupiter
Jupiter orbits happy we're going to
calculate we don't calculate first of
all but again you're talking about just
rephrase the sentence you you can you
can use that you can use that sentence
in in science you can say it the point
is that I'm trying to make is that
whenever you say that you have to be
aware that the word orbit at all times
no matter how
use it in physics is a verb so you can
say the orbit of Jupiter but at that
point you're not really talking about a
noun even though it's the subject of the
sentence all you're saying is I'm going
to talk about di't in airy of Jupiter
and I'm gonna call that the orbit or the
motion or whatever you want to use in
there but you're talking about the verb
with the action you're not talking about
look I've got an orbit in my hand and we
have the same problem with the word
field field vision now field is a
concept again in its dynamic concept
which people don't understand that but
it's a dynamic concept of threading yeah
the threads are moving and the moving
threads that's what we call the field
okay and so on okay but yeah the point
here is that the word continues is an
adjective it can only be used to say the
table is continuous or a cube is
continuous the correct word is incessant
motion is incessant not continuous can
be incessant yeah yeah okay yeah well it
is in fact in the universe it is
incessant motion but you're right it can
be and it is in our case but my point is
that's the correct word to use and
incessant in ordinary speech what is it
it's an adjective we can't use it as an
adjective in physics in physics it's an
adverb
why because adverbs qualify verbs and
adjectives qualify nouns the you can say
the table is red so so now the table
what does that mean now you're using the
word red as an adjective and that's
correct you can't say motion is red or
the itinerary is red okay you can't use
that kind of language in physics at
least you can do it in poetry maybe but
not in physics and in physics similarly
you can't say you know the table is
continues but you can say motion is
incessant eternal perpetual you can say
all that but you cannot say motion is
red or continues or straight right and
you can say you can say motion is
rectilinear or curved in linear you
cannot say the motion is straight no
that's the wrong word straight is what
an arrow is straight is what the table
is you can
say that but you cannot say or the edge
of a cube but you cannot say that motion
is straight so so we have a new language
and be aware that have to be applied to
verbs that are similar but it's like
you're taking one concept and giving a
word splitting every concept into what
applies to motion itineraries and the
other part of the concept the other word
applies to objects
yeah it's a black-and-white issue that's
the point if you're gonna use adjectives
only applied to objects what is an
object that we test shape you can say
that the table is red you can say the
tables continues you can use it in that
sense likewise if you're referring to
something that has motion to some
dynamic concept like information
information is dynamic concept I think
right because it's like a flow of
information I guess maybe you can even
say that book but it's really well again
you have to know what what you're
referring to if you're referring to
orbit you know - it's under all
circumstances the word orbit is a verb
now they've turned orbit into orbit ah
you know the orbital the energy levels
you know the orbital of an atom and
they've turned this this verb into a
noun they turn infinite which is an
adjective
you know the infinite table and they
turn it into infinity into a noun and
they do all these magical things in
mathematics those are prohibited in
physics there is no such thing as
infinity why is why do you draw this
Chris penis I like things crispy I like
my my cereals crispy that's why it's
Chris penis it's besides precise it's
black and white there's no ambiguity but
if you say well the orbit it turned into
the orbital and the orbit okay then then
you're messed up because now you don't
you can't follow the converse for the
dissertations and because
say things like the motion is read or
something like that it's it's worse a
man what is a black hole I mean we don't
have a definition for the term black
hole and when you look at the
definitions there's two irreconcilable
concepts or definitions one is as a
black ball you know the this big star
condense it condenses and it shrinks to
what and this is from the NASA site okay
air too well no no no in fact it doesn't
know if you go to NASA site you'll find
several of these there's not only one
there's like three or four notions of
this it says to the size of New York
City the black hole so this big star
right it lost all its stuff and
condensed and shrunk and compressed all
the matter but it doesn't disappear into
a singularity as we always thought if
you go to the NASA site you'll find this
don't take my word for it it shrinks to
a ball the black ball you know this is
the eight ball or a bowling ball the
black bowling ball the size of a New
York City so so they're talking about an
object and then when you look up the
definition and or you see other sites
they'll say that the black hole is a
region a region of space-time so here we
have a star that shrinks so much that it
becomes a region of something else so we
have a problem because they don't have a
definition for black hole is the black
hole you know an object a standalone
object like a ball does it shrink to a
ball it's this ball that has so much
mass or does your shrink so much that it
turns into nothing singularity point
point nothing because it has no size no
volume and it's part of space-time it's
a it's a hole that takes you to another
universe it turns into Bugs Bunny's
holding the ground we're not talking
about the earth we're talking about the
hole inside the earth so so is is the
black hole a standalone ball black ball
or is it a hole is it Bugs Bunny's hole
and again that's the problem we have and
that's because of language that's all
language that's the you know when when
they say that space-time is a knob
Stephen Hawking says is in a brief
history of time it's a four dimensional
object and don't try to imagine it hold
it what do you mean an object I mean you
you might have doubts about space you
might say well I think space is material
tonight but surely time is not an object
time is a concept and if I take a
concept wants a tree it doesn't make a
four-dimensional tree okay I have a
three dimensional rock plus love I don't
get a four dimensional object because of
that okay this is the issue the issue is
that these people are blending concepts
with objects and they get away with this
because of language it's all language
[Music]
voguing frames and what's the question
okay yeah what I'm saying again time
should be separate from motion and
they're not the same because time
involves two motions okay time requires
a comparison of two motions to distinct
notion what do you call friends oh when
I use the word frame I use it only in in
the context of the universal movie I'm
saying that if we take cross sections of
time right you take it just the cross
section of this universal continues
Universal movie and you have to think of
it not side by side all these frames but
again like stuck together like pages on
a book then it's continuous but we
separate like we can chop time or the
motion of all the locations in the
universe op it at one point in time say
we froze the universe at that point in
time and now we have distance all we
have is distance to the test object
that's all we had that's where the
problem comes
it's like when we were talking about the
rope or the thread we're saying
distances between the rope or the thread
you have to take a chunk
oh yes continue oh yeah object you're
essentially when you're talking about
two or more locations you're taking
chunks from this continuous movie
correct correct you can't really take a
chunk out of a movie right and it's it's
it's a it's a it's tricky but again I
keep bringing you back to square one and
the square what is the following we're
gonna use the word motion consistently
in in physics and what do we mean by
that we mean that when I say something
new the rock moved I'm saying the rock
occupied two or more locations does it
mean that I saw it does it mean that I
filmed it does I mean I recorded it no
it just means that if we take all all
observers out of the universe if we
could do that if we kill all the
observers you know like I always say
it's like the Mafia you kill all the
witnesses the rock moves when I say the
rock move I mean that the rock occupied
two or more locations and we don't need
an observer for that the rock moves by
definition because that's what the word
motion means in that context I think the
part where someone could get confused
yeah but it had two or more locations
you're saying you're putting someone by
definition summoning a witness yeah but
that's the the point that I'm trying to
make here is that it's not it's not and
primarily because you know we're not
saying that we need to have an observer
that saw the rock move or that's or that
measure or that filmed or recorded in
some way that the rock occupied two or
more locations we're saying in the
absolute beat the moon was moving before
any humans were born on earth what do we
mean when we say the moon was moving we
have to define that that situation when
there's no observers because there were
no observers millions of years ago or
built or at least up a few billion years
ago at least there were no observers
here on earth there was no life
you know we take it before life began on
earth was the moon movie yeah the moon
was moving what do we mean by that we
mean that it occupied two or more
locations was there time well there was
no one to make the comparison so there
was no time but we had motion that's my
point the past only exists in our minds
what I'm saying is we're not invoking
the past but when you bring up the past
when you say two or more locations you
brought up the past
no no because because we defined the
terms see you see your invoke you're
bringing time and we haven't even got to
the word time I'm still I'm still let me
put the definition once more because
it's important here let me put the
definitions up again the these are the
only four words I never got beyond these
four words because I never was able to
get to exist or to time or to anything
else right straight any of the other
words that we use in fizzy I only got
this far ah can with can I with these
four words talk about the motion of the
Moon and I can and I can tell you that I
can I haven't defined any other words
those are the only four in the entire
dictionary as of this moment right there
are no other words except the words I
used in between so these are the only
key words that I've got in there okay so
if these are the only four words can I
talk about the motion of the Moon and I
can safely say that I can because I'm
saying the moon is an object it has
shape there is distance between I don't
know the moon and the earth okay and the
moon has location because there is a
separation between the Earth and the
moon and other objects in the universe
and I can say did the moon occupy two or
more locations I'm saying I don't know
if it did because that would be an
observer that would invoke the past but
if if the moon occupies two or more
locations I'm going to refer to that as
motion that's what I say that's my
question how can an object occupy two
locations that's an irrational thought
no it's now two or more location because
that's what I'm saying two or more
locations how does an object
by two or more locations I've never seen
a ball be in two places at once
at once what is this at one see that's
what you're implying
I'm not imply you bring time in and I
have me by time you have I could show
you to look let me show you watch
carefully here's the ball over here now
the ball is over here I only saying that
if not occupies two or more locations
and obviously no object can occupy no
two object in occupy the same location
as it does in quantum mechanics okay
quantum mechanics they they have two
things they have two objects can occupy
the same location okay and an object can
have two locations at once that's how
they explain the slit experiment by the
way so they have these irrationalities
in normal science in rational science an
object can outtalk two objects cannot
occupy the same location and one object
cannot be at two locations okay at once
but that's when we bring the word time
in but when we just say location it says
the distances from all objects to the
target if you're going to talk about two
or more locations obviously we're not
talking about the same location yeah but
then but then you can't talk about two
locations
you just location twice yeah and or or
you're saying then then yes we have a
frozen universe so I think two locations
is is a good definition but again it's
up to you folks to tear into pieces but
that's my argument is by definition the
moon moves by definition and what is the
definition whenever we say the moon
moves were saying it occupied two or
more locations that's that's my argument
okay so now you know when you see
someone up there who criticizes you that
my answer to that question okay going
back to the rope okay yeah can it be
said that the rope has motion in the
sense that the Rope the rope does move
the Rope moves it does move but not in a
way that not in the way we always
thought that something like this moves
keep in mind that an atom can move this
way in that way in that way but an atom
is really sliding along the ropes like a
bead on an abacus right wire of an
abacus it just slides through there it's
something like that but that doesn't
mean that the ropes don't move it's just
that the Rope doesn't move in the way
you know you in atom moves
well once slides the other one can move
sideways up and down or like mr. Plato
said yesterday the six motion the six
motions up and down forward and backward
and side-to-side okay that's what us
broke can do I cannot roped world I
don't know not exact because of what it
is it's a remember when when it slides
like an an abacus it's it's it's a
reconstructing it reconstructing itself
in the direction of motion that means
the threads are coming and forming part
of that that part of the atom and it's
releasing thread behind so it's like I
don't even know if there's a analogy for
that I'm trying to think of an analogy
here but this at the point the point is
for any specific rope along which an
atom slides the threads are going in
into the atom one goes through the
center of the atom the other one goes
around it and behind it it releases that
same thread so it's moving along that
thread like breaking into the rope okay
that's what it's doing that's the idea
and then it can move sideways in the
same direction along another rope and so
on but the ropes also can move because
all the if you move
well the the there's two ways of looking
at this and again that's for smart
people to to see which one you think is
is more correct you have two scenarios
one scenario is the is my little ball
here okay one scenario is this you know
that the one scenario is that the son
trolls the earth around along all these
ropes right that's one scenario
now here's another scenario the the
earth encounters new ropes as it goes
along and the other rows remain behind
it okay so that's another scenario
possible so obviously I would think so
because I think that's what's happening
I think the Sun is twirling around but
remember something remember something
some of the atoms on earth are
constructed with ropes that come from
very very far away and those ropes don't
move as fast as the one within the solar
system right and so we're crossing these
ropes that momentarily thing in the
distance it moves and my point here is
that when the earth comes around you
know let's say there's a rope there's a
bunch of ropes connecting the Sun to the
andromeda galaxy or to some star out
there right very far away so those ropes
you know they they move but very slowly
you know versus the two objects which
they unite compared to what's happening
within the solar system the solar system
in comparison is porting around real
fast but what does that mean it means
that the earth comes around right and
goes through those ropes and for a split
second for the moment it goes through
that area that rope forms part of your
atoms it's so weird
and then it continues that rope remains
behind and only the ropes that are
throwing you around the Sun is is what
you know primarily constitutes you but
remember every time it goes in there you
have this rope not not not
[Music]
some of them go through you and some of
them are connected to you because they
end in your atom so you have both
situations you have a situation where
you're going right through this this
coaxial let's call it a coaxial right
and you're going through the coax yield
the rope that is connected to your atom
you know keeps going with you
but the rope that went through you was
connected to the atom in the Sun you
pass through it momentarily it may be
formed part of your atom I don't know if
it did maybe it does maybe it doesn't I
don't think it does it just goes through
and you go keep going through as the
earth twirls around the Sun so we have
to look at that whole scenario how how
it is in detail okay it's it's a new
physics for a different day what do you
mean resize well obviously atoms they're
all pumping constantly like ice well
again what I'm saying is whenever an
atom moves every second of that every
Pico second of the day you know an atom
is pumping torsion waves okay so it's
doing its quantum jump it's a great
speed and so it's constantly moving and
it's constantly growing and getting
small and it's like a spontaneous I mean
if poor's quantum jump is correct what
we're doing is seeing a little heart
going Boom Boom you know just pumpy
torsion waves to other atoms and so this
motion is constant so the atom is
constantly getting bigger and smaller
what an atom changes location does it
resize towards the center
you can say okay yeah it's assumed that
let's assume Bruce is such a thing even
Adam is way out on the fringes and it's
coming towards everything isn't it
reeling in all the rope and essentially
getting bigger I know no because the
it's releasing rope behind remembering
where it's at the edge well I don't know
I guess it's it's coming in and see
you're talking about an atom that's way
out there outside of everything
a lonely atom yeah but as soon as it
comes in its got someone up behind it
why well because it's on the edge but
what is the idea just a whole bunch of
atoms actually actually actually I have
a better explanation for that and in the
book and that's that the edge of the
universe is woven is is scanned by
threats
yes magnetism that's on the edge of the
universe but but see when you come in
from that from these fourteen threads
you do have threads behind you
so you're reconstructing the rope but
you're something you're releasing behind
it's not like you're not you know you're
not pulling everything behind you
especially if you're just one atom
that's coming in you've left some atom
behind to the side of you and then
farther behind yeah but there's more
yeah yeah but the other guys are pulling
you know you're eating more rope well
assuming that were the case the question
there would be maybe if the magnetic
field increases I don't know I'd have to
think about that that's a good question
so I'll take that as an action item as
homework we talked about prime movers
and things they move on their own
yesterday as opposed to something that
gets moved upon right where it is it
reacts to you say that atoms pulsate or
Punk essentially grow and shrink
repeatedly yes this self-propelled
or reactive in other words is the atom
doing the moving or is the atom being
pump that's a good question because if
every atom in the universe is doing this
the question is if the other atoms are
inciting our atom our target atom right
we have we have a test atom right and
and there is and in a an influence for
example if if the Sun has an atom that
is pumping faster because suddenly a got
squashed and releases thread and we have
higher frequency and now that frequency
travels all the way that higher
frequency the shorter wavelength right
will link links travel to this atom and
now this one begins to pump faster then
there's been an influence from one atom
to the other okay so in that sense atoms
do influence other atoms but the
question here is again we're talking
about the origin of motion did any one
set this in motion in other words was
there a moment where which I explained
yesterday and I do explain that also in
the book where I'm saying God has a
frozen universe he's got you know
everything just static and now suddenly
how does he create motion for the first
time well all he's got to do create to
create motion is to move one atom in one
direction and all the other atoms in the
universe adjust their location with
respect to it so all you got to do to
move the entire universes move one atom
if I want to move God right now it's
very easy I just moved my hand like that
and God is changing his distance with
respect to my hand and he can't avoid it
you know this is a power that I have
over God I changed the distance whether
he likes it or not and and by moving my
hand I'm moving god but that's the point
the point is that motion all you need to
do is move one atom in the entire
universe you live everything with
respect to it well in in a sense that
again if we start from scratch where we
say let's start with no motion in the
universe everything is frozen right how
to create motion for the first time in
one atom well I'll just got to do is
move with respect to all the others yeah
that's all we would need right that
would be the scenario
and I don't think that's ever happened I
think the the famous universe as we call
it all the matter in the universe was
always in motion there was no point
where someone kick-started it and we
have trouble with that because we always
have this idea that there's been an
origin a starting point and there was no
starting point to the universe to the
matter in the universe because again the
word universe means matter in space and
space is not a medium like water like
air space is nothing there is no such
thing as space all we have is matter
just floating with respect to each other
every atom with respect to each other
and I think that never did one of those
atoms stand still with respect to the
rest of matter in the universe always
constantly in motion
there was no origin to motion so so to
say did an atom start moving no we can't
say that all we can say is that yes when
one atom vibrates at a higher frequency
it does influence the next atom there is
that kind of influence mutual influence
from atom to atom we do have that so
there is an influence now can this one
influence the other one also if you can
get this atom to vibrate faster it's got
to influence the other guy and in fact
you can do the opposite you you which is
what they do in some of these laughs
they try to freeze they try to reduce
the frequency of an atom so it doesn't
vibrate as much and that's what we call
cold because vibration is hot and less
vibration is cold and they try to get it
to close to zero degrees Kelvin which is
you know what is it 273 degrees below
zero centigrade and that's as cold as it
yet but they never got there they got
closer I think the three degrees Kelvin
I think that's what they've managed to
achieve how they measure that I'm not
sure but they've got to very cold which
means that that atom is barely moving
and the wavelengths got to be very long
but then how do you you know if you put
a fire underneath that what are we
saying we're saying that your your
imbuing motion to that atom now it's
vibrating at higher frequency the rope
it releases that rope or the vibration
of that rope causes the broke to have
shorter
clinks and you have higher frequency and
now you know you have that atom at
higher temperature if you were to
measure if you could measure that one
atom you would have a higher temperature
so is it safe to say that the atoms
aren't pulsating it's more like I mean
their policy but they they are doing the
posting their being posted by other
atoms like it's it's a two-way street
it's they are pulsating and they are
influenced in their pulsating because
you can you can modify it by just take
water and heat it you know till it boils
what have you done well you've you've
you've sent higher frequency to that
atom and that's vibrating a higher
velocity or frequency and so now yeah
that's why it boils that's why water
boils and so you have influenced that
atom we can't influence atoms now the
the atom still moves on its own but
other atoms can influence that atom by
making it you know move at a faster rate
so I think we have both situations so
it's it's a tricky question because here
we have one of those little dualities
but it's a rational duality in this case
the atom moves and the atom is moved
it's a mover and moved at the same time
it moves and it influences the atom next
to it so they're both things are
happening so when when we have mister
who was it Aristotle in fact the Stoics
already used that they said what are the
Stoics defined also motion not not
motion they were defining existence the
word exists and they said what does
exist mean and they said well it's very
simple
that which can move something else and
that which is allowed to be moved in
other words what exists is that which
can move because it's been moved by
something or which can move something
else that's what they call the existence
that's what they refer to when they said
exists and that's essentially your
question you're saying doesn't add them
you know have motion or is it influenced
by motion the question and the answer is
both it does have motion
and at the same time it can influence
motion be influenced by motions got both
okay and in that sense it's we can say
it's a duality but it's a rational one
unlike the what is it the wave packet
that's that's an irrational duality or
are you changing something with
frequency you're doing both remember all
this is one one set one one system the
whole universe is one system some stars
are far away and we don't consider them
but really it's all one system what we
have is and we take the basic system
which is two atoms bound by an
electromagnetic rope okay and so what an
atom typically let's say we come to an
atom and we are to a pair of atoms we
just see them pump boom boom boom and
the rope yeah well they could they could
do it alternatively I'm not sure about
that you know I've considered both
scenarios you know where they pump
alternatively or when they pump
simultaneously but the point here is
that I'm trying to make is the phone you
you come to two atoms you you you have
God's eyes you can see these two atoms
right so they're pumping and then the
rope is sending the torsion back and
forth you know along the rope in both
directions now what happens somehow you
stimulate one of them so this one begins
to pump faster or vibrate fast because
there are several motions to to an atom
there's vibration there is pumping and
so now what happens that doesn't go
unnoticed by the Rope the Rope now if
this goes faster what's it doing is
making the Rope torch that torque at a
faster rate atom vibrating moving back
and forth in a 90 degree parallel that's
not that you're not adding to the rope
it's pumping faster than you are both I
think all vibration
I think this is the way I visualize this
all vibration motion of an atom whether
it's shaking whether it's pumping any of
anything that you can imagine are up and
down I think all of them affect the rope
in one sense in other words if you were
to if you were to stimulate if you could
see if you had God's eyes and you were
to able to stimulate one of the atoms
just to go up and down or back and forth
or pump I think all of them would have
an effect on the rope and the effect
would be because it's vibrating at a
higher frequency or higher rate I think
that shows up in the rope as higher
frequency in other words the rope now
what I mean by that is the links will be
shorter because it it suddenly gets the
stimulus and so the Rope is torquing a
certain range suddenly you you give it a
whack and now it's going to do - it's
moving faster and that faster since
light always travels at the same speed
it has to be a trade-off between
frequency and wavelength and when I'm
saying is the wavelength gets shorter
and you have more links right that's
what I'm saying
at a higher frequency at a higher
temperature anyway you want to look at
depending what you're analyzing so so
that's that's the sense that I'm that's
how I'm visualizing this whole thing of
motion the definition the definition
because people have again they use the
synonym the word change that's used
constantly and that's that's where we're
at today and people are not aware of the
history of the word motion of what has
happened throughout time and it turns
out that you know throughout the
centuries they've all defined it in the
same way they defined it with synonyms
and and so we did not have a definition
we still don't have a definition
officially out there we're proposing the
first definition scientific definition
of what motion really is and so when you
encounter someone and he talks about
motion
since it's the fourth word on the list
here you can see fortunately I still
have it up there it's a it's a key it's
a key word it's a key word and you can't
do without it in physics and people take
it oh yeah motion we know what motion is
like Newton said no we don't so we need
to clarify it's two or more locations
and that's where I see the big problem
with the majority of people who
encountered this definition for the
first time there's a clash of cultures
but and obviously yeah remember this
language is is is a problem because
people are not used to the language and
they want to bring the language of
ordinary speech into the discussion and
you can't allow that to happen and so
this is where we run into trouble people
are not used to the language and when
you say something they're understanding
something very differently or they don't
pay attention to the wording because
they're not conscious like you know
whenever someone talks about object
motion exists I get on I get nervous I
get on all fours and start getting
nervous and people don't have that
reaction because for them these words
are not important we have convergence of
slack ropes so they become threads
because always they become threats like
loose threads
you mean like swinging threads is that
what you're saying you know swinging
threads that's not an atom that's
magnetic field so if we're talking about
threads and you're talking about like
the slack of you know extra threads out
there the only way I can see threads
again is always a function of spinning I
think that always when you have see a
thread and we talk about the thread
we're talking about spinning and and
that immediately takes it to the
magnetic field context whereas the rope
is always straight that's why some
people say you know
rope theory or are they said yeah the
rope swings around or block no no no the
thread is different than the rope in the
thread whenever we have a swinging
threads we're talking about a magnetic
field whenever we have a robe it's
always straight just a little bit loose
well how loose is a little bit okay okay
tomorrow we deal with atoms if you have
questions on motion because maybe we
haven't exhausted all the issues here I
just want to maybe recap real quickly
motion cannot be continuous
it's got to be incessant we got to use
an adverb incessant is an adverb for the
purposes of physics oh it's incessant
perpetual eternal you can use any word
of that nature and it's going to be
considered an adverb because an adverb
is what qualifies a verb on the other
hand an adjective such as continuous
only can be applied to an object okay in
in science and physics the other one is
that all these definitions as you can
see still on the board have to be
comprehensive in fact some people think
that they can go in there and say well
you know I like your definition of
location but I don't like your
definition of motion no you can't do
that
this this is all comprehensive in other
words all these definitions are tied
into one another and you can't shake one
of them and not believe and believe that
you can get away with shaking it because
you're you're shaking the foundations
well if you can't maybe because again it
depends on which words you're gonna use
to define like you know and we have more
words there that come later like exist
and what is straight what is a dimension
and so on there's there's a series of
words that we must define in physics in
order to talk intelligently and my only
point is that you get a
be careful with shaking some of these
words you know what is a concept you
know a lot of these things people say
well you know I don't like your
definition here I'm gonna use this other
definition but all the rest I'll accept
not always can you do that you got to be
careful because if you it's like having
this structure of toothpicks or matches
and you put one matchstick out in the
whole structure Falls and that's exactly
what happens here so you got to be
careful when you put all around with
these definitions I'm not saying you got
to memorize them maybe you can improve
on them in fact but the point is these
definitions you got to be very very
careful because they form the
foundations of physics okay and so it's
a comprehensive system one the other one
you can't use adjectives for motion and
the third one is well as my son
challenged me you know he thinks that
maybe we need time to define motion and
I'll just have to beat them up after
class today yes that's the point to be
able to question no no right and that's
what we're here for
we simply want to talk about this
question tomorrow okay yeah yeah or well
it also remember the slack also is
absorbed by the Rope the Rope can
observe slack in the form of amplitude
and it also in in the speed in which it
torques in other words the frequency in
the wave in case in our case the link
length and so on down the line
so anyways we'll continue tomorrow and I
hope that clarified some points that
were not clear yesterday we'll see you
tomorrow bye bye